as the united states expanded between
the 17th and 19th century indigenous
people were forced off lands they had
inhabited for thousands of years
european settlers took land to establish
farms u.s laws such as the dawes act
stripped an estimated 364
000 square kilometers of tribal land
many historians anthropologists and
tribes have documented the trauma and
impact of this forced relocation
to build on this body of work
researchers set out to quantify this
land dispossession on a large scale and
analyze its effects
the researchers used many different
sources to map native land prior to the
19th century
a key one included a collection of maps
published by the u.s government which
showed seeded tribal land up until the
late 1800s
they also explored data created by
tribal sources
the researchers found that over 54
million square kilometers of land were
held by native people this is almost
surely an underestimate
gaps in the data don't mean indigenous
people didn't reside on those lands
today tribes have far less recognized
land
an almost 99 reduction to what they
occupied before the 19th century
including shared land practices between
tribes
for many indigenous people dispossession
was complete
43 of tribes don't have any federal or
state recognized land base
one challenge to this study was matching
the names of historical and present day
tribes
many nations today represent more than
one group of people
the researchers found that forced
migration moved several tribes far from
their historical land
for example the modoc people originally
lived in the klamath basin
now their reservation is in oklahoma
2565 kilometers away
after creating these two data sets the
researchers explored how various
attributes of present day reservations
compare to those of historical native
land
indigenous communities hold spiritual
and cultural connections to land that
cannot be quantified
but the researchers focused on factors
they could measure
one being access to natural resources
using u.s energy data sets they found
that indigenous lands today are 24
percent less likely to sit over oil and
gas reserves
this took away the opportunity for some
native people to profit in the
extractive economy the united states
established
although many tribes resist oil and gas
producing wells on their land
the researchers also evaluated whether
currently recognized land was more
vulnerable to climate change using four
different criteria
extreme heat
long-term drought severity
annual precipitation and the potential
for wildfires
today about half of present-day tribal
lands had an increase in days above 100
degrees fahrenheit
although historical and current
indigenous land show a similar risk for
wildfires
several tribes face a significant risk
today
precipitation declined in present-day
land and there was some evidence of a
greater risk for drought severity
particularly in the oklahoma tribal
statistical area
the climate crisis has already impacted
many tribes
ubique villages in alaska are grappling
with sea level rise and sinking
buildings while the navajo nation
struggles with a dwindling water supply
this study shows that these accounts are
not isolated experiences many native
communities are more vulnerable to
climate change
the researchers hope this study will
help inform future policies that will
heal these inequities
[Music]